for nearly 90 years now the Empire State
Building has stood as not only a symbol
of the skyline of New York but also a
symbol of American ingenuity and
determination so in honor of the soaring
towers creators the nation's first youth
poet laureate that's Amanda Gorman
headed to the observation deck with
pianist John batiste who's also musical
director at the Late Show with Stephen
Colbert so here is their performance of
the Republic rising an original
composition created for this special
broadcast
[Music]
steel spears through vapor the tower
taper like a child's pencil this a peak
of progress and potential built when the
Big Apple had to grapple with the Great
Depression but in that time of dire
stakes this Empire state still desire to
scrape the sky and when the cloud high
building glows it shows and all its
concrete and steel that a real and
country can still heal can seek an ideal
of opportunity and unbroken hope all the
possibilities that this pen of a tower
wrote here here until the screams of
Subway here where those dreams of
someday here the melting pot with
geniuses jive to jazz and hurry non-stop
to hip hop on chopped up Street blocks
we bebop
we wild we want we stunt
we strive we hustle we hungry we run
free here we come we won country we
ain't dancing who began the task of
building a tower together not stats
with steel or stone but hearts and home
we home a nation that's a myriad like
Manhattan on its block you'll find the
black the Latin the indigenous the
religious levers beyond labels the
disabled community foreigners in
sojourners on each corner of this land
in this cacophony of a country we reach
down long hands that we all might stand
together where we belong our war rings
strong like King Kong we mount a tower
and pound or chests blessed with power
we do not rest we do not weaken we are
the skyscraper we are the beacon or
spine steel spire straight in this time
of higher dire stakes let this fire
awake as to the faith before our eyes
but of a public doesn't require hate to
rise globe dances you're tired you're
aching you tomorrow we'll be shaking the
skies we cannot fail so we will not fall
we were moved by the call of this
Colossus of a tall steeple
it proves that when you only include the
few you only injure all people but when
we retire our gates we build up a new
these entire United States it's an
empire to inspire look great
[Music]
Wow goosebumps a meadow now we know why
she's the youth poet laureate I like a
cacophony of a country our country we
ain't done see I like we do not rest we
do not weaken we are the skyscraper we
are the beacon
very nicely done yeah like I like that
all of it was was dedicated as a tribute
to the tower but also the men and women
that built this tower many of them are
anonymous five of them gave their life
in the creation of this building 250,000
jobs created in the process of going
1,400 feet in the air and that was a
worthy tribute and Jon batiste not to
the music that he did with we'll be
right back with rather on the Empire
State Building stay with us